I'm looking at this like a marathon I'm
not gonna be the first I'm gonna get
there you're gonna specially with the
theory literally dying right now but if
it's truly the fattest I've ever been
eating the bacon eater
yo so guys on the to like Sean I'm
Andrew we are single guys and today
we're gonna try to smash down 50,000
calories in 24 hours and Christmas on
try yeah
[Music]
that's 13 bacon aiders you don't get any
13 begging it I'm gonna do my best but
I'm think I'm top out of seven so
somebody can like pick up the slack so
personally I think I'm going to be
eating the most calories out of the day
I think if we had a leaderboard what
[ __ ] is this is a challenge I'm gonna
eat the most awful I don't think I'm the
same I do like six meals a day but
they're usually like balanced yo you
guys already do this uh yeah ain't no
time to do it I mean we're already here
so I guess all right let's get it
alright let's smash it
I'm gonna show you right now what I know
I know we wanna know I mean this is a
team but it's also like individual
[ __ ] like I want to be LeBron James
party y'all can be like Rondo you know
I'll bet Rondo assist me pass me a prize
Hey ladies
our game is wide open yeah oh let me go
in that thing I don't know
okay no mom cuz that one was in front of
me and I just turned around and it was
in food
Brown James you know what this this poor
thing working
yeah I mean you got a dedication in this
video bro
I'm glad one of us knows it's a way of
life Sean if you're real I'm sorry if
you're real right now bro you'll drink
this
oh you won't do it John you won't do it
right well I just want to say my main
goal for this challenge is to not be
last what that's everybody's goal
I am the win so who you gonna be Thank
You Sean all you've had is a lemon pound
cake and not even all of it I'm tired it
is this is that John it all fairness
actually did catch Sean earlier uniform
yes come back to that point an Amana or
a banana
there's food of the day in this
ridiculous challenge yeah obviously you
could tell how many how many calories
105 calories in the average Nana fruit
snacks
in the first place
so I have no confidence in myself
however I have confidence and Aunt Ruth
that he would do worse than me on this
challenge as long as I'm not last I'll
still probably feel I just wrapped up
the initial part the challenge I need to
clear up some space there's no calories
in this well hopefully I'm a convert so
I can like refresh this as the in-house
losing pair in this challenge I think I
think you need to stick with me I'm
gonna lose we gotta lose together
to be the loser of this challenge all
right
yo Matt so do you think I'll be able to
finish this 50k color challenge with the
boys so I'm gonna throw up yeah I know I
will keep smashing he's down I got
calories to go we got a long way to go
and I'm gonna start known the single
boys aren't ready for this I'm ready
oh all right so the cakepop was about
170 calories this is about 510 the
double smoked bacon and then if I finish
the white mocha that's gonna put me
somewhere over 1,000 calories so that's
a good start I think Blake I think if
somebody throws up is gonna be black or
Sean Blake or Sean will throw before I
throw up
that's a guarantee I'm gonna get my
stuff done I think my speech also has to
do a video where we pick dates I'm gonna
eat every single bite you're my boy if
he he's not doing the chant challenge
cuz he's too worried about his fitness
but I got to finish this whole thing to
keep my calorie count up so that I could
beat Sean because you know you are so
brave okay well we only got to do 12,000
until it doesn't 500 oh it's split
between four people oh that wouldn't
change that's that's 13 Baconator so oh
I would just add I would have cheated
nah dude do you think you could eat 13
baggy meters 24 hours yeah about say not
in a day you know what next video if he
tries to eat 13 bacon aiders let's do it
so we had that whole team dinner thing
about two hours ago and I am stuffed I
did the calculations on my phone and
sitting down with those guys ate a
thousand calories right there I have to
do this ten more times new set new food
more calories yo Sean Sean yo okay I got
a lot of stuff goin bro
yeah how you feeling about your stuff so
far oh really
would you eat somewhere all right so
it's lunchtime and I'm eating Q's
leftovers right now so yeah I don't know
how many calories are in half a chicken
sandwich from Wendy I so much I can't
even think about it's a lot amen I'm
gonna be looking forward to seeing your
12-thousand get done pull your side
amazing I mean how about five okay
looking forward to it all right
looking forward to it okay I'm on my
second of three meals my clients get a
little difficult the difference I'm
trying I'm trying I've been eating a lot
today I'm just saying
expensive so we're doing a single guys
he's not twelve five
okay so my question here is someone has
to end up in last place right who do you
think is more likely to end up there
mere Andrew be honest you directly at me
Andrews I know something skinny might
fool people but it doesn't fit me aha
aha
you hear that there you have it the
people have spoken
Spencer I decided three calories a day
three calories Tamiya Tamiya
well thanks bro you're really helping us
out right now you know I'm literally
dying right now
every shoot is getting harder and harder
[Music]
Andrew anything that catches your eye
right now daddy go cheese steak right
yes well you still have the energy to
even pick something that's true question
I'm in a win I'm here to win welcome
with the fat cells right now boys say
they got some food let's go they're
talking home we got going on we go
honestly I feel so good right now like
I'm not even kidding
I felt horrible for a long time and I'm
just now getting back to like being a
regular person I swear
is the pepperoni pizza burger from fat
cells it's gotta be of these like
thousand calories in there this girl
can't go wrong with a cheese day I'm
saying let me get your number girl let
me holla praise it good enough for you
to consume it's good
chomping of doing a lot of filming good
enough to finish on doing a lot of
filming and no II look I mean they're
filming odd they ain't nothin
Xiao Yu a cameraman
[Laughter]
Gulshan you ain't even eat nothing put
the full sandwich did you twelve
thousand calories for a regular person
that doesn't heat like that
I don't think it's possible for for
someone to chew so you're telling me
that Katie twelve thousand calories in
the next twenty wait what I can do that
okay alright yeah watch I'm not gonna
cheat either yeah yeah I saw me earlier
I'm not gonna cheat I'm not gonna cheat
alright so I'm pulling back up to
Wendy's look up some bacon aiders get
these calories up yeah can I get three
bacon aiders let me have one combo and
then just two burgers I'll take a large
yeah I had a cook you can and I said so
that's gonna be like
at least like 3000 4000 calories so I
just left work still doing this
challenge you're getting out free
samples of protein drinks
boom I don't know how many calories is
but add it to the list Silas I'm coming
for you
I took their time I'm still full from
the entire day so we're dinner I'm
eating kimchi reppin Korea it's not
working out I'm sorry I tried at home
now that I made I think this will
probably add another 500 or so I'm
really full but I was heading home I've
done my Wendy's but I decided I needed
to stop by and get something healthy you
know balance things out because the
amount of putting me in today is
ridiculous so I think this is gonna be
pretty good for me at least you'd like
to get a nice little balance so hope I
can make it through when I get home I
eat the rest of these baked inators
[Music]
[Music]
this is truly the saddest I've ever been
eaten a big inator so I'm gonna add all
the stuff up but I think I'm definitely
gonna be able to get my you know 12,500
before you know three o'clock tomorrow
so yeah my finishes out tonight probably
wake up in the morning and see the guys
aren't go to IHOP with use packing some
more calories but I'll make this happen
I'm tired I feel like I'm definitely
slowing down but I'm not gonna do this
[Music]
I'm saying
quickly a snack it's 106 I'm trying to
add all these calories man about to eat
the other half of a cheesecake
you know I know everybody else is
probably sleep probably chillin but we
still have a challenging we still have
to work it it's 450 2 a.m. right now I
got so hungry that inside to eat my fat
cells from earlier every calorie counts
right
one more Wendy's Burger left from last
night gonna heat that up even before I
get to work
final bite for the morning I'm gonna get
these calories in last day the boys got
me pulling second diabetes on a plate
never you know we still going hard still
wanting our baby
I just wrapped up another video 50,000
calories is coming through pretty good
boom guys were waking up round kick was
he in the house these combine or buy
like what or put your class
we're coming come before you tryna best
we're coming alright today for lunch we
go ramen and nice bowls about 600 in
here it's chipping away at that total
man tip analytic yep this is this is
what like our last meal it's 12 now if I
can get this down wait like an hour to
get more more and we'll be good to grap
it up or you could just look out for
yourself in the long run this is it for
me is the end of line I try I'm still
winning over here i'ma be honest I
didn't throw up
[Music]
but I might like I should have yeah we
didn't quite reach 50k as a as a squad
you know some of us went hard others did
not
should make you feel any better I feel
great I believe you should yeah I gave
up in the first like two hours and I
think in the end I'm the real winner
here this still 3 p.m. we have to get
back to work so one of the story is
don't do this mmm yeah I'll leave not
condone people ever trying this
challenge we saw it on the Internet the
Internet is a dangerous place you start
[Music]
is